yes hello welcome this is a video only 15
minutes game
Plateau nice DC and played
gladly okay
times the sex because I don't know it
going to play
so what time
BabyOne
look at
and great Kings Indian Game at Nakamura
will be
wedding on the queenside and
black  is meeting so let's play the king
India
systems
magic ja 907 now Mary
ja on a short night of too is possible
to go for
sea five
sea five DVB five and style of the Banco
in German in general go to Samy don't
really like
for black  the five Setups
of playing
with for the king in the 90s and
before Yos like
againstream 6 move aha the form that is
on short very aggressive will
the questions
pressure is on here and sea five
on See five at some point
once completely
move like Rook be  hate your problem age
5 anyway okay
white and
to take one believe
it
wow yes okay
yes know it's not easy for white open
Update King side
peace to challenge the night on age 5
Sound Nike g G3
yes yes that's a
new simply take on age  6 and takesy
form
of course
should be good for black really
take on the forever
giving up the exchange for great
compensation
das ist ein Tag für die great
yes
going directly for made on age 700
don't get it
i for you five but I'  ve got too nights
alright
some last
No No
whatever and the problem
yes okay
just once to you have someone and my
expencers take it
alright so night and g-5
yes but there is something on it
this is Queen
giving
possible night Air Force Check
okay not Queen
out and game
cker Video built have nowhere
that like to mention is
sometimes get request from Videos in
German German language German which I
simply don't do anything anymore for the
YouTube channel the origins is simply
please please
English Videos
a company of the can really  comments
um if he's not a friend Youtube series
and German and you get them new serious
with me in German
protected and
it's really long long way and tell you
even Trading to taking Spawn
yes now generally not so easy and
difficult
yes um 19
progresses connected with porn  moves
like
this is ver
yes this is the
back
okay
to use the Queen on the on the king side
and Queen
okay
okay let's and
red much Widget there are new ones under the
sixpoinland and the seven times the
might beer der rected taking and years
no the  5 e takes de five night five
example
m
Baby
it
that's the Tipico way to attack on G7
okay well the 5 what about night defive
like the five night five and tracking made
on you seven
five night five
like the
death G6
so hm night TV
we  are that is good
is the problem with nightify G6
at the end of
the text the 5 is Justin Exchange with
pornhub
ja
cken
Förster
make short to not get back rank mated
yes limiting the night a bit and Danny
Rook the one and D6
use the king over  to the form
ed
better even
will be difference
wow
the night there are have a square
okay King up to the Fort
move the night Amine